Guten Tag, mein Name ist Yusuf Seçkin. Ich bin heute der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Ich werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen.
Dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden. Falls Sie Fragen haben,
dann ergeben Sie bitte nicht, mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Sublin Şimid. Könnten Sie bitte den Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchtebieren?
Sublin mit Z-U-B-L-I-N. N. N am Ende ja.
Schimid S-C-H-M-I-D-T.
Sind Sie Herr oder Frau Schimid?
Herr Schimid.
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Schimid?
55.
Ihr Gebustdatum bitte?
Ja. 1. Juli 1970.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 73.
Ihr Gewicht bitte?
74 Kilogramm.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja, natürlich habe ich, Herr Doktor.
Wie heißt er oder sie?
Er heißt Herr Renkler.
Renkler mit R-E-N-K-L-E-R.
Mit G, nicht K, G.
Renkler.
Was für Sie heute so uns Herr Schimid?
Welche Beispiele haben Sie?
Herr Doktor, seit gestern Abend oder Nachmittag
hatte ich Schmerzen bekommen.
Habe ich Schmerzen bekommen.
Wo genau tut es Ihnen weh?
Ja, Rückenschmerzen habe ich.
Und im Verlauf der Zeit hat es schlimmer geworden.
Heute kann ich nicht ertragen.
Ich kann sagen, es ist sehr schlimm.
Ich habe ein stechendes und brennendes Gefühl im Rücken.
Und Schmerzen ist immer da.
Das ist sehr schlimm.
Ich kann nicht bewegen, ich kann nicht drehen.
Beim Liegen auch habe ich Schmerzen.
Beim Liegen auch.
Haben Sie im Ruhe auch Schmerzen?
Entschuldigung?
Im Ruhe, im Liegen.
Im Ruhe auch.
Beim Bewegen ist es schlimmer.
Aber im Ruhe habe ich Schmerzen.
Strahlen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ich habe Schmerzen im Lendenbereich.
Rücken im Lendenbereich.
Strahlen aber nicht ganz im Rücken.
Links oder rechts?
Mitte.
Aber es gibt keine Ausstrahlung?
Nein.
Gibt es irgendwelche Auslöser dafür?
Was ist passiert, Herr Schmidt?
Ich weiß nicht Herr Doktor.
Das ist selbst passiert.
Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Ich habe alle gleiche Dinge gemacht.
Aber es war passiert.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder allmählich aufgetreten?
Zuerst nachmittags war es nicht schlimm.
Aber Schritt für Schritt wurde es schlimm.
Heute Morgen kann ich nichts ertragen.
Aber manchmal ...
Wann haben Sie die letzte Schmerz?
Im Nachmittag.
Und am Mittag?
Am Mittag.
Im Nachmittag.
Wann hatten Sie letztes Mal diese Schmerzen?
Ab und zu, ich kann das nicht genau sagen, aber ab und zu hatte ich Rücken Schmerzen.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt?
Ja, manchmal war ich beim Hausarzt und hat mir einige Vitaminen gegeben.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich Muskelschmerzen habe.
Ich habe einige Muskelschmerzen und Medikamente genommen.
Ich habe Schmerzen genommen, aber jetzt ist es schlimm.
Haben Sie dieses Mal gegen diese Medikamente genommen?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht angenommen.
Wurde bei Ihnen außer Muskelschwannung eine andere Diagnose festgestellt?
Nein, mit Rücken Schmerzen nicht, aber habe ich Zuckerkrankheit und so weiter.
Wir kommen zu Ihrer Chronikgeschichte, aber jetzt sprechen wir über aktuelle Beschwerden.
Haben Sie noch andere Schmerzen, Herr Schmidt?
Ja, jetzt habe ich Rücken Schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Wie stark sind Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 10 am stärksten ist?
Es ist 8 oder 9, ich weiß nicht.
Könnten Sie uns das Gespräch zum Ende aushalten?
Ja, ein Schmerzmiter wäre schön, Herr Doktor.
Ja, bitte schön, ein Schmerzmiter und ein Glas Wasser.
Ich danke Ihnen, aber ich hatte einmal einen Anaphylaptik-Schock gegen Ibu Brown. Was haben Sie mir gegeben?
Sie haben recht, Herr Schmidt. Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien?
Ja, ich habe Ibu Browns Allergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ich hatte einen Anaphylaptik-Schock. Ich konnte nicht atmen und habe zwei Tage im Intensivstation geblieben.
Ich hatte einen Anaphylaptik-Schock, ich konnte nicht atmen und habe zwei Tage im Intensivstation geblieben.
Ich gebe Ihnen andere Medikamente. Können Sie es nehmen?
Vielen Dank. Ich lebe noch.
Haben Sie Kribben oder Taupassgefühl, Herr Schmidt?
Mein Rücken ist wie ein Ameiserlauf.
Im Fuß oder im Knie?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nur im Rücken?
Ja, im Rücken.
Haben Sie Muskelschwache?
Nein, aber jetzt kann ich nicht bewegen, kann ich nicht drehen.
Können Sie Ihren Fuß bewegen?
Ihren Fuß?
Ja, können Sie laufen?
Ich kann nicht laufen, jetzt habe ich sehr starke Schmerzen.
Wie sind Sie hierher gekommen?
Mein Sohn hat mich mitgebracht.
Haben Sie Schwellungen, Überwärmung oder Rötung im betroffenen Bereich bemerkt?
Habe ich nicht bemerkt, aber mein Lendenbein ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Mein Sohn hat berührt und auf der Wirbelsäule hatte ich sehr starke Schmerzen.
Verstehe.
Haben Sie Fieberhälfte mit Schüttelfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nicht so, ein bisschen. Mir ist übel wegen Schmerzen, denke ich.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit etwas Schweres gehoben?
Nein, Herr Doktor, ich habe alles gleich gemacht.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin Angestellter bei der Gemeinde.
Haben Sie körperliche Belastung bei der Arbeit?
Ja, manchmal arbeite ich körperlich.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit gestern Abend kann ich nicht essen.
Ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen, vielleicht wegen Schmerzen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ab- oder Suge genommen?
Ich bemerke nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang und Wasserlasten, Herr Schmidt?
Ich leide unter chronischer Verstopfung.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit ungefähr zehn Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme ein pflanzlicher Mittel.
Was haben Sie?
Ich habe kein Problem.
Können Sie gut schlafen, Herr Schmidt?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut, aber gestern Abend kann ich nicht schlafen.
Haben Sie ein Schlafstörungen oder nur Schlafstörungen?
Gestern Abend war total schlimm.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Atemnot, Husten oder Herzrasen bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich keine.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Bluthochdruck haben.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen außer Bluthochdruck?
Ich habe eine Zuckerkrankung.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck und Zuckerkrankung?
Seit zehn Jahren habe ich Bluthochdruck.
Seit 20 Jahren habe ich Zuckerkrankung.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme Metformin zweimal täglich.
Abends und morgens.
In welchen Dosis nehmen Sie das?
1000 mg.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ich nehme Kaptopril. 25 mg morgens.
Einmal.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, aber als ich Kind war, hatte ich Windpocken.
Welche Behandlung hatten Sie?
Ich erinnere mich nicht gut, aber hatte ein Schmerzmittel.
Oder ein kibasenkender Mittel.
Außer diesem Medikament nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Nein, nehme ich nicht.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Mit zwölf Jahren wurde mein Wurmvorsatz entfernt.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Vor drei Jahren wurde ich wegen Hüftefraktur operiert.
Ich hatte Platten und zwölf Schrauben.
Hatten Sie einen Umfang?
Nein, ich habe gestolpert und dann hingefallen.
Es war sehr klein, aber ich hatte komischerweise einen Hüftgelenkfraktur.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Wurde bei Ihnen Osteoporos gestellt?
Mein Hausarzt hat mir einmal gesagt, dass vielleicht ein Osteoporos ein Rückenschmerzen verursacht.
Aber nicht genau.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, nach dem Anamnistgespräch werde ich eine Labo-Untersuchung veranlassen.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie oft rauchen Sie? Und seit wann?
Seit 30 Jahren eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke jeden Abend zwei oder drei Rotwein.
Zwei Gläser Rotwein.
Und ab und zu ein Flaschen Bier.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Mit meinen Freunden oder Freundinnen.
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nach dem Gymnasium. Das ist ganz normal in Deutschland.
Ja, natürlich.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgende Frage nicht persönlich.
Aus medizinischen Gründen fragen wir, haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Ja, im Gymnasium habe ich probiert.
Zwei Joint, aber ich rauche regelmäßig nicht.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Wie wohnen Sie?
Wir leben zusammen mit meiner Familie.
Mit Ihrer Frau und Kindern, oder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja, sie sind gesund.
Gut zu hören. Sie sind im Gymnasium eingestellt.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Mein Vater hat vor vier Jahren einen Apoplex erlitten.
Tut mir leid zu hören.
Entschuldigung, einen Schlaganfall.
Deswegen konnte er nicht gut laufen.
Wie alt war er?
Er ist 78.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter leidet seit 20 Jahren mit Knochen.
Haben Sie Gechümmel?
Ich bin ein Kind.
Sind Sie verständigt, dass Sie mit dem Gymnasium leben?
Ja, ich habe alle Impfungen gemacht, aber ich weiß nicht, ob alle sind.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Hausärzte regelmäßig?
Ja, ja, besuche ich regelmäßig.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, wir waren vor vier Jahren im Kanarien-Insel wegen Urlaub.
Ich bin in letzter Zeit in den letzten sechs Monaten.
Vielen Dank für die Info.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Herr Doktor, was habe ich vermutet?
Ich habe Angst.
Keine Sorgen, wir sind für Sie da.
Wir tun alles für Sie.
Herr Schmidt, wie gesagt, werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Danach werden wir die Labornterzüge voranlassen.
Wenn es so geht, werde ich eine operative Diagnostik voranlassen.
Dann können wir entscheiden.
Welche Apparat verstehe ich nicht?
Operative Diagnostik bedeutet bildgebende Diagnostik.
Ich brauche zum Beispiel eine röntgenische Computertomographie.
Ok, verstehe ich. Genau Herr Doktor, vielen Dank.
Gerne.
Ich möchte Ihnen kurz etwas erzählen, was ich in deiner Aufnahme gesehen habe.
Ja, gerne.
Es handelt sich um Sublin Schmidt, ein 55-jähriger Patient.
Er wurde am 1.7.1970 geboren.
Er war 1,73 Meter groß und 74 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund seit gestern Nachmittag.
Er war bestehender, stöchender, brennender, zunehmender, plötzlich aufgetretener,
rückenschmissen, ohne Ausstrahlung.
Er gab an die Bewegung, die Schmerzen verbessern und die Bewegung verschlimmert.
Gibt es einen Unfall?
Er hatte keinen Unfall, Frau Obererstin.
Ok.
Fener gab er an, diese Beschwerden schon mal gehabt zu haben.
Deswegen war er schon Hausarzt.
Der Hausarzt hat Muskelspannung gestellt.
Er hat Vitamin und Schmerzmittel verschrieben.
Aber dieses Mal hat er keine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegen Parasthesie im Rückenbereich vor.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 8 bis 9 von 10 bewertet.
Die Frage nach Ödema-Hautverfabung wurde verneint.
In der vegetativen Anamnese sind folgende Beschwerden bekannt.
Neusea inapetens wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Obstipation seit 10 Jahren.
Die mit pflanzlichen Arzneimitteln behandelt.
So wie Insomnie wegen dieser Schmerzen.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet er seit 10 Jahren an arterieller Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt er kaptopril 25 mg einmal täglich ein.
So wie seit 20 Jahren an Diabetes mellitus.
Dagegen nimmt er mitformen zweimal 1000 mg täglich ein.
Er hatte Varicella Zoster als er Kind war.
Bei ihm wurde mit 12 Jahren eine Opendektomie durchgeführt.
So wie vor 3 Jahren wegen Hüftfraktur eine Operation durchgeführt.
Er hat Allergien gegen Ibuprofen und Hazelnuss.
Ibuprofen Allergie ausgesetzt sich mit Anaphylaktisch Schock.
Hazelnuss Allergie ausgesetzt sich mit Zungenbödem.
Ich glaube, wir können auch Anaphylaktisch Schock sagen.
Er ist Raucher seit 30 Jahren.
Er rauche seit 30 Jahren ein Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinkt 2-3 Gläser Wein täglich und ab und zu mal Bier in einem Monat.
Er hat zweimal gejohnt als er im Gymnasium war.
Er ist verheiratet. Er lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat 3 gesunden Kinder.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich Osteoporose bei der Mutter.
Sein Vater ist mit 78 Jahren an Apoplex verstorben.
Er ist vollständig geimpft. Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstiagnose lautet auf Osteoporose.
Dafür schiebe ich eine Familienanamnese.
Er hatte vor 3 Jahren eine Hystpraktur.
Das schiebt sich an Osteoporose.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kommt.
Wandscheibenvorfall, Muskelspannung,
Koksarthros.
Die Diagnostik...
Hat der Patient eine Osteoporosediagnose vorher gehabt?
Sein Haushalt hat ein Gedanke, es könnte Osteoporose sein.
Aber bisher keine Festdiagnose gestellt.
Wie hat die Hystpraktur bestellt?
Er hat gestört.
Dann hatte er Hystgelenkfraktur.
Er hat keinen Unfall.
Und niemand hat eine Diagnose?
Nur ein Gedanke.
Bisher keine feste Diagnose gestört.
Und der Patient hat nur zwei Risikofaktoren.
Familienanamnese und...
Familienanamnese.
Aber die anderen Risikofaktoren sind wirklich hoch.
Der Patient hat gestört.
Dann hat er sein Hystgelenk gebrochen.
Und der Patient ist nicht herrisch alt?
Er ist 55 Jahre alt.
Und männliche Geschlecht.
Wir erwarten Frauen mehr als Männer.
Aber es könnte sein, das ist mein Verdachtstdiagnos.
Welche Labouruntersuchungen möchten Sie?
Labouruntersuchungen überprüfe ich Blutbild, Entzündungswerte, Vitamin D Werte, Vitamin D, Phosphat, Parathormon, PTH und Thyroid Werte.
Okay. Und hat der Patient Diabetes mellitus?
Ja, er leidet seit 20 Jahren an Diabetes mellitus.
Ja, ist Diabetes mellitus gut?
Wenn ich die Diabetes mellitus überprüfe oder kontrolliere, werde ich HbA1c und Glukoswerte auch überprüfen.
Okay.
Zunächst würde ich körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchungen achte ich auf neurologische Untersuchungen.
Ich überprüfe Motorik, Reflexe und Sensibilität, weil er an Parastese leidet.
Zu weiteren Diagnostiken würde ich operative Maßnahmen durchführen.
Zunächst würde ich einen röntgenländischen Bereich veranlassen.
Danach werde ich Knochendansitometrie durchführen.
Was meinen Sie? Knochendansitometrie?
Das ist eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Leider kann ich es nicht.
Wir können Knochen überprüfen. Wie kann man das sagen? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ist das eine CT-Methode oder Bildgewende?
Wir können bei der Röntgenuntersuchung diese Parameter überprüfen.
Okay. Und?
Sollte sich meine Verdachtstheatose bestätigen, würde ich Vitamin D, Bifosphonat, gegebenenfalls Olymdogonat verschreiben.
Ich empfehle den Patienten regelmäßige körperliche Aktivitäten und Ernährungsberatung.
Okay. Und der Patient achtet darauf? Stürz?
Ja, ich empfehle ihm auch, er sollte darauf achten.
Und Nikotin und Alkoholkarenz?
Ja, er trinke viel Alkohol und er rauche viele Zigaretten. Ich empfehle auch Nikotin und Alkoholkarenz.
Okay. Wissen Sie, wie ist die Ernährungs- und Bewegungsstation des Patienten?
Ich habe darüber keine Frage gestellt, Frau Berestin. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich fragen.
Okay.
Ja, weitere Fragen.
Und der Patient nimmt viele Medikamente. Diese Medikamente können Osteoporose verursachen?
Ja, mit Vomin und Kaptur-Bild habe ich keine Ahnung über dieses Thema. Aber ich glaube nicht.
Wie definieren Sie Osteoporose?
Mit Osteodanstometri oder Knochendanstometri können wir diese Diagnose bestätigen.
Ich erinnere mich nur an Z-Skore, aber leider kann ich das jetzt nicht erklären.
Okay.
Z-Skore ist eine Beurteilung, eine Methode. Wie gesagt, ich erinnere mich nicht daran.
Und jetzt empfehlen Sie die Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Ja, sie erleiden heftige Schmerzen.
Kann das eine Fraktur?
Ja, um meine Differentialdiagnosen auszuschließen, werde ich ihn stationär aufnehmen.
Okay. Und empfehlen Sie eine konservative Therapie oder eine Operation?
Wenn ich einen Fraktur habe, werde ich eine chirurgische, orthopädische Konzilveranstaltung um die Therapie oder Operation optimieren.
Okay. Nach der Therapie empfehlen Sie die Patienten Bewegungstherapie und Physik?
Ja, eine krankere Gymnastik, regelmäßige körperliche Aktivitäten, Ernährungsberatung, Nikotin und Alkoholkarrens.
Okay. Danke schön.
Danke.
Herr Doktor.
Guten Tag. Herr Oberarzt, ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne ihn Ihnen vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, bitte schön.
Ich berichte über den 55-jährigen Patienten, Herrn Zublin Schmidt, der 1,73 Meter groß ist und 74 Kilogramm wiegt.
Herrn Schmidt stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern 5-tehender Persistierender Rücken-Schmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 8 bis 9 von 10 bewertet.
Der Patient klagte über Nausea und Obstipation seit 10 Jahren.
Fragen nach Fiberschütelfrost, nächtlicher Hyperhydrose, Ad-Dyspne und Tachycardie wurden vermeint.
Außerdem hat der Patient inapetens und insomniere Schmerzen.
Der Patient leidet an Diabetes mellitus typsivae seit 20 Jahren, arterial hypertoni seit 10 Jahren und chronischer Obstipation.
Als er Kind war, hatte er Varicella Zoster erlitten.
Er nimmt regelmäßig Metformin 1000 mg morgens und abends, Kaptopyril 75 mg morgens und pflanzliche Ansteigmittel gegen Obstipation.
Beide Patienten wurden mit 12 Jahren Apendektomie durchgeführt und vor 3 Jahren Osteosynthes wegen Femur-Halsfraktöre durchgeführt.
Die Anamnesie ist unaufwendig. Beide Patienten sind mit Nusse-Allergie und Ibuprofen-Allergie bekannt.
Sie haben sich mit Anaphylaktischen Schock und Zungeödemen ausgesucht.
Er ist vollständig geimpft und ist ein starker Raucher und raucht seit 30 Jahren ein Schachtel Zigaretten.
Er trinkt 3 bis 3 Gläser Wein täglich seit 25 Jahren und ab und zu Bier.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass sein Vater an Apoplex vor 4 Jahren gestorben und seine Mutter an Osteoporose seit 20 Jahren leidet.
Er ist verheiratet, hat 3 Kinder und lebt mit seiner Familie. Er ist angestellt bei der Gemeinde.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Wirbelsäule oder Lombervertebrafraktur.
Die Anamnestik ist wahrscheinlich wegen Osteoporose hergestellt.
Die Differenzdiagnostik betrachtet Vertepratum, Muskelspannung und Metastase.
Um meine Verdachtstheorose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten zunächst körperlich untersuchen.
Ich teste ganz Wirbelsäule ab, ob es Druckdolenz gibt und ein Schwellen, Rötung und Hautveränderungen gibt.
Ich werde die Wirbelsäule verändern.
Ich werde auch Lomber-MRT oder Lomber-ST durchführen, um einige Tumoren auszuschließen oder Lomber-Pathologen auszuschließen oder Fraktur zu bestimmen.
Um die Differenzdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ein orthopädisches Konzil ist auch sinnvoll.
Ich werde ein Venösenzugang legen, Schmerzmittel verabreichen und Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde auch Grosse Blutbild, Kalzium, Phosphat, Elektrolytin und Tumormarke, Paratormon, Glukos und HbA, Glykolise, Hemoglobin bestimmen lassen.
Ich werde Knochen-Danstometrie verändern, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Ein Patient kann auch an psychologischen oder wirbelsäulen Erkrankungen leiden.
Besonders Romatoid Arthritis und Ankylosanthespondylitis kann in Betracht kommen.
Deswegen werde ich auch Entzündungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Ich werde auch HLA27 bestimmen lassen.
Der Patient ist männlich und hat Lendenbereich Schmerzen.
Auch Metastase kann in Betracht kommen.
Besonders Prostat Metastase kann auftreten.
Deswegen werde ich ein paar Laboruntersuchungen durchführen.
PSA und Total PSA werde ich auch bestimmen lassen.
In der Geschichte von Vererkrankungen gibt es eine sehr interessante Information.
Ich möchte ein bisschen darüber sprechen.
Welche Vererkrankungen leidet der Patient?
Können Sie es nochmal sagen?
Typ 2 Diabetes mellitus, Arterialhypertonin und wahrscheinlich Osteoporos.
Als Kind war es Varicella Zoster.
Ist diese Krankheit bei diesem Patienten als Differential Diagnose wichtig?
Herr Oberarzt, Sie haben recht. Das kann auch ein solcher Zoster sein.
Bei der Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob es Hautveränderungen, Rötungen und Bläschen gibt.
Ohne Bläschen können wir auch eine Herdveränderung feststellen.
Nach Rücken Schmerzen können wir nach 2-3 Tagen die Bläschen feststellen.
Auf jeden Fall kommt eine Varicella Zoster als Differential Diagnose.
Welche Ethiologie kennen Sie bei Osteoporose?
Der Patient ist ein starker Raucher und Alkoholtrinker.
Der Patient hat eine besondere Risiko und eine familiäre Belastung.
Ich denke, dass ein Sport verursacht werden kann.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall den Patienten fragen, ob er Sport oder Sonnenlicht trägt.
Welche Symptome sprechen gegen eine Metastase?
Der Patient hat keine Gewichtabnahme und keine Beschwerden.
Z.B. Schwellung oder andere Körperschmerzen.
Der Patient hat seit 10 Jahren Obstipation.
Das kann ein Kolonkarzinom sein und auch eine Metastase.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie ein CT durchführen würden.
Können Sie das ein bisschen erklären?
CT ist ein ganzes Verfahren.
Mit Hilfe von CT können wir Knochen, inneren Organen, Verletzungen, Blutungen, Tümoren beurteilen.
Die Untersuchung dauert 5-10 Minuten.
Der Patient liegt in Röhre und bleibt ohne Bewegung.
Man muss ruhig sein.
Wenn er Angst hat, müssen wir ein Beruhigungsmittel verabreichen.
CT ist beim Schwangerschaft oder Kontrastmittel Allergie nicht nutzbar.
Sie sind kontraindiziert.
Die Strahlung ist gering und nicht gefährlich.
Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Ich empfehle, den Niko-Konsum zu reduzieren.
Am besten aufhören und den Alkoholkonsum reduzieren oder aufhören.
Und regelmäßig Sport zu treiben und Milch-reich Produkte zu essen.
Ich empfehle den Patienten und Vitamin D zu nehmen.
Vielen Dank.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde ihn gerne vorstellen.
Es handelt sich um Suplin Schmidt.
Er ist 55 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,73 Meter groß.
Er ist 74 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient stürzte sich wegen gestern Abend aufgetretener Lumbargie ohne Astralung vor.
Er erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen bei der Belastung schlimmer im Ruh verbessert sind.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 8 bis 9 von 10 einer Schmerzskala bewertet.
Er war oft Hausarzt wegen dieser Probleme.
Aber es wurde bei ihm keine bestimmte Diagnose festgestellt.
Die Einnahme von Analyse und Antispasmodik hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Beschwerden gehen mit Parastese, Mielgie und Muskelspannung einher.
Er wurde von seinem Sohn zu uns gebracht.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Schmerzbedingte Inabedenz.
Die Inzomen und Amethyst.
Er hatte seit 20 Jahren Diabetes mellitus.
Seit 10 Jahren Arterielle hypertonik.
Dagegen nimmt er mit Formin 1000 mg zweimal täglich und Kaptopril 25 mg ein.
Außerdem hatte er als Kind Varizellen.
Er hatte eine sehr lange Osteopatie.
Dagegen nimmt er eine pflanzliche Mitte.
Aber die Name sollte geklärt werden.
Er reagiert allergisch auf Hazelnuts.
Das ist eine sehr starke Analyse.
Außerdem hat er eine Provenzallergie.
Er wurde mit zwölf Jahren eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt.
Als Kind wurde bei ihm wegen Femur-Hassfraktüre eine Operation durchgeführt.
Er wurde mit Platten und Straub behandelt.
Er ist Rauchhörer.
Seit 30 Jahren trinkt er eine Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinkt jeden Tag zwei bis drei Gläser Rotwein und gelegentlich eine Flasche Bier.
Er hat zwei Mal eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt.
In Besuch auf die Familienanamnese teilt er mit, dass der Vater mit 78 Jahren ein Apoplex verstorben ist.
Die Mutter hat seit 20 Jahren Osteoporose. Er ist Einzelkind. Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Der Vater mit Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig. Er arbeitet als angestellter Eingemeinder.
Er ist verheiratet, wohnt mit Familie und hat drei Kinder. Alle Kinder sind gesund.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Osteoporose aus, dass der Patient dafür typische Symptome aufweist.
Der Patient hat Lumbargie ohne Ausstrahlung und er hat sehr wichtige Geschichten.
Als Kind hat er eine Femurhalsfraktur ohne Unfall.
Seine Mutter hat auch Osteoporose.
Diese Sprache für Osteoporose ist eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Die Mutter hat auch eine Dyskoproblastus.
Sie hat eine Tumorometastasie.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten die Vitalparameter überwachen.
Dann werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde dabei achten, ob es Störungen, Motor, Sensor oder andere Veränderungen gibt.
Danach werde ich die Wirbelsäule palpieren, ob es sichere oder unsichere Frakturzeichen gibt.
Außerdem werde ich das Symbol der Haut untersuchen.
Ich werde dabei achten, ob die Hautfarbeveränderungen in der Haut verhindern.
Dann werde ich die Wurzeln der Haut untersuchen.
Ich werde dabei achten, ob es andere Veränderungen gibt.
Neben der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich die Laborunterzüge annehmen, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dann werde ich die Blutbil BSG-SRF Elektrolyte, Kaltium, Phospho, Vitamin D, TSH bestimmen lassen.
Danach werde ich eine Röntgen veranlassen, um mögliche Knochenfrakturen auszuschließen.
Herr Kollege, welche Röntgen veranlassen Sie?
Das ist eine spezielle Röntgen-Untersuchung.
Damit werde ich die Aufhellung der Knochenstruktur durch die vermehrte Strahlentransparenz kontrollieren.
Ich erwarte auf zwei Ebenen Lindenwerfer-Säule.
Ja, wir werden solche Röntgen untersuchen.
Ich achte darauf, ob es vermehrte Strahlentransparenz gibt.
Was beachten Sie bei der Röntgen? Ich beachte darauf, ob es vermehrte Strahlentransparenz-Zeichen gibt.
Machen Sie weiter.
Ja, bei der Unklei-Befundung werden wir die Röntgen veranlassen, um mögliche Knochenfrakturen auszuschließen.
Welche Knochenfrakturen können Sie auszuschließen?
Die Tusschusps, Pyrropsis und mögliche Metastasen auszuschließen.
Und Knochenfrakturen?
Ja, Knochenfrakturen. Die haben recht.
Machen Sie weiter.
Ja, die Knochenfrakturen werden von den Patienten ausgesucht, um mögliche andere Pathologien auszuschließen.
Zum Beispiel die Tusschusps, Pyrropsis.
Es wäre sinnvoll, um den Patienten eine Osteodentzimetrie durchzuführen.
Sollte sich meine Tertarztdiagnose bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten stationärer aufnehmen.
Zunächst werde ich den Patienten einen Zugang vorlegen und danach den Patienten Analytika und Antispasmodetika einleiten.
Und ich werde den Patienten Kalsium, Vitamin D, B-Phosphonat verabreichen.
Und nach dem Akutbeamtung werde ich den Patienten empfahlen.
Und wenn Sie mit dieser Forderung einverstanden sind, werde ich die Plante untersuchen und fortsetzen.
Herr Kollege, wie können Sie die Diskuprolaps auslösen?
Wie können Sie die Diskuprolaps auslösen?
Mit Anamnese gibt es keine Ausstrahlung. Das sind sehr wichtige Symptome für uns.
Und der Patient hat keine Parastese und Parasite. Das ist Schipris für Osteoporos.
Aber um die Diskuprolaps auszuschlissen, werde ich die Zähne der Wirbelsäule und der Gegendenfass MRT durchführen.
Welche Metastasen denken Sie in diesem Fall?
Prostatmetastasen sind wichtig.
Wie können Sie die Diagnostizierung des Prostatmetastas auslösen?
Ich werde die Zähne der Wirbelsäule durchführen.
Machen Sie Biopsie?
Ja, die Gegendenfass.
Wir müssen eine Nadelbiopsie um mögliche Prostatkarsenoma auszuschlissen oder zu diagnostizieren.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Und Sonne?
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig. Sie haben recht.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen. Bitte nehmen Sie unsere Info-Test und Ihre Zertifizierung.